no we're too agreeable you gotta finish
your statement
no that was pretty much it like it
delays like it used to be my mom got
married at 21. the average age of first
marriage is like 28 and 31 in the uk
yeah it's it's insane so basically
whether women believe it or not i think
they're naturally red pilled we will buy
and do anything that tells us that we're
young for as long as possible because a
lot of our worth is what we're born with
which would be fertility which obviously
as you age that sort of goes down so
things that make you think you're
younger longer than you actually are
birth control is one postponing marriage
is one pursuing a career is another one
so we we kind of like do these things
but
you will get old one day so i try to
tell women in their 20s don't plan for
your life
based off of the options that you have
now like think about how you want to
live at 60 do you want a man to be there
or not some women 100 like they're
definitely okay with the independent
women but i i try to look at the happy
independent women that are actually out
there doing their phd research they feel
like their time on this earth was
valuable but
the independent woman i'd be seeing is
like these fake small business ceos and
ceos nothing is no publicly traded
company they're working at the dmv
trying to tell me i'm making a mistake
by depending on my man now get out of
here
oh my god that's so true
they're so angry and i know that oh man
i could get into it you know i worked at
a couple store for a year
bro so a couple stores really code for
working at a sex shop i was actually
ignoring i just wanted to see what was
up when i tell you that every single one
of us on staff is pathological in one
way or another i'm not playing i like
all of us were messed up in some way
shape or form so when you're looking at
these women that are working in regular
smegular jobs yeah i'm suspicious
wait so what do you mean you were messed
up like because you said you had some
sort of transformation i think i saw
that on your story once
yeah yeah um okay so
so long story short
i grew up in a lower socioeconomic
status and i grew up with a lot of risk
factors being a single mother home
meaning that
i was physically assaulted for about a
decade just if my upbringing and i
didn't know that that was going on until
i was about 23. so it was very quirky
which is just code for i had complex
ptsd and i had no idea but
no man wants to marry you or have babies
with you when you're freaking out all
the time and crying all the time and
just absolutely terrified about living
life so
i first i had to get some type of
diagnosis and then after that i got
cognitive processing therapy which is
you kind of think through your triggers
there's multiple different forms of
therapy that you can seek for ptsd which
i don't even really like that it's
called ptsd because that's how you're
supposed to respond when you're being
physically assaulted because you're
supposed to kind of be concerned and
free down a little bit yeah um
but that helped me a lot to chill out so
that i could stop misinterpreting my
partner being assertive in having
boundaries as something much worse
wow is that common like a common issue
amongst people that have like gone
through physically abusive situations
i think i think most
let me how can i wear this i think most
people that have been
a b used
they don't know
very few people ever find out so these
are the women that you're seeing that
are pathological out there on the dating
market they have no idea that they have
these severe cognitive distortions so it
it takes a long time for people to get
treatment for ptsd to be honest because
it's it's usually small they start
having some issues at work start having
some issues in relationships and then
all of a sudden it's like oh like you
got fired you're an alcoholic now you're
twice divorced on your way it just it
eventually you hit some type of point
where okay like let me go see your
professional or you just end up homeless
or an addict i mean pick your poison
so you felt like or what was most
effective for you was you said
cognitive behavior sorry you got to say
that again no no it's okay cognitive
processing therapy okay so
you
i'm a very a thinker a critical thinker
and a bit of a way and i don't well i'm
not trying to elevate myself it's just
i've been asking some very big questions
for a very long time like adults did not
like me as a child it's very curious oh
me either
i know exactly yeah okay you know you
know because you're you're asking your
aunt why are you going on another date
with him if you don't like him and
you're literally eight years old and
they're staring at you like no you
didn't i'm like yes i did what's the
answer so anyway
i asked i asked why my trainer was
overweight at like
[Laughter]
why would i oh man
sorry keep going keep going no no it's
it's so funny it's so funny so um okay
okay where are we at where are we at
cognitive
oh content processing therapy okay okay
cognitive behavioral therapy exists but
it's for anyone you can be traumatized
and have cognitive behavioral therapy
you can have this anxiety depression or
you could just be a regular person let's
say you don't have baseline pathologies
group in a very secure situation um you
can
get cognitive behavioral therapy just to
be a more well-rounded person that's for
everybody but cognitive processing
therapy is more so
for uh people that have been traumatized
because trauma does rewire your brain
there's everybody knows that at this
point so what you do is you go through
the the more traumatic memories so
complex ptsd like it's so disputed i'm
not even sure that it's really a thing
like they try so hard to define things
that they can't define how about i was
just i had my life threatened on
multiple instances let's just go from
there so you you pick
the more traumatic memories and you go
through them and it's things like
when you're a kid sometimes you think
something bad happens to you because
you're bad but really
when you're a kid and an adult chooses
to physically assault you
that is on them they're making the
choice to hurt you there might be
reasons for that but you typically as a
child there's nothing you could have
done to change that but you think that
as the victim and it stays with you even
into adulthood well maybe if i had just
behaved a little bit better so you end
up coming to this adulthood just
thinking that you're a bad person who
can't do anything right so i went
through this cognitive processing
therapy broke things down added some
logic and i was able to really assume a
lot less responsibility for the things
that happened to me and that that helped
me to date because i was very at risk of
being childless and alone just because i
was like freaking out all the time over
nothing yeah
so what advice do you have for like
young women
um who want to get married
think about it in your 20s don't wait
until you're 30. and i don't mean that
just because of the wall because if you
take care of yourself as a woman
you should still look pretty damn good
at 30. audrey hepburn look amazing at
30. i could i could just name so many
women that are attractive at 30 although
your fertility does go down by that age
the problem is more so if you make it to
30 being single you probably picked up
some bad habits along the way and
they're really hard to undo
at the same time i think when women get
married very young so that's kind of
what i did when they get married very
young they might not know themselves
because i got married when i was 20 and
when i was 25 i was a completely
different person and i was attracted to
different kind of things it was just all
the way different so think about it in
your 20s if you want to get your career
lined up because let's be real a two
income household goes a lot further
sometimes than a one angle one income
household
get you can get your career done by 24.
and i'm not kidding you can be 16 to 18
you get yourself in um
like a dual enrollment program in high
school so you graduate with your
associate's degree or maybe you decide
to serve in the military four years done
you got a gi bill and you get into a
stem degree you just you can have your
career set up halfway if not fully by
age 24 and then you can go out there and
pick any duty you want because i get
women want to know if we can actually
make things happen